flughafen kabul vergangener samstag 10
uhr 30 der mann der gleich zu hören ist
hat jahrelang als orts kraft für die
bundeswehr gearbeitet
das ist das tor hier stehen die leute an
hier sind mehr als 10.000 leute die
sicherheitskräfte drängen sie
zurückschießen in die luft
er hat angst vor den taliban versucht zu
fliehen doch am flughafen kommt er nicht
weiter
leider waren da keine deutschen soldaten
keine deutschen beamten und es war auch
keiner da der uns exportiert hätte und
die amerikaner haben eine nicht
durchgelassen ein totales missmanagement
vergangene woche haben wir zum ersten
mal mit dem 28 jährigen gesprochen wir
zeigen sein gesicht nicht nennen ihn
amir um ihn zu schützen er ist bei
freunden in kabul untergetaucht
manchmal denke ich dass mir die taliban
den kopf abschneiden und ihn an meine
familie schicken das ist wirklich hart
ich habe wirklich angst
mehr als fünf jahre hat er mir im
medienzentrum in masar i scharif
gearbeitet seite an seite mit
bundeswehr-soldaten haben sie hier einen
informations krieg geführt gegen die
taliban was internet und im radio den
zdf gab mir 2018 ein interview
wir wollen dass die menschen verstehen
dass es uns um den aufbau einer
zivilgesellschaft geht das in
afghanistan soldaten ihr blut vergießen
damit man hier irgendwann einmal
anständig leben kann
heute schickt amir uns fotos von damals
die zeigen dass seine angst berechtigt
ist er hat eng mit der bundeswehr
zusammen gearbeitet seinen ersten
vertrag hat er mit der bundesrepublik
deutschland abgeschlossen vertreten
durch das bundesministerium der
verteidigung doch diese tätigkeit endet
2016 danach war mir beim medienzentrum
angestellt gleiche arbeit nur bei einem
subunternehmen das hat heute fatale
folgen eine woche bevor die taliban
kabul einnehmen am 9 august schreibt ihm
sein ehemaliger arbeitgeber hat die
bundeswehr ihrer beschäftigung für die
deutschen streitkräfte 2016 endete sind
sie nicht mehr berechtigt am einreise
programm teilzunehmen
am vergangenen donnerstag um 16 uhr dann
die kehrtwende die bundeswehr ruft er an
er sei auf der liste an mir fährt sofort
mit frau und kindern los doch am
flughafen kein durchkommen
ich habe versucht die bundeswehr zu
überzeugen mehr zu helfen und mich zu
retten sie haben mich im krieg benutzt
und jetzt ist mein leben in gefahr
wir verabreden mit mir in kontakt zu
bleiben
fest steht die bundesregierung hat viel
zu spät damit begonnen ihre ortskräfte
in sicherheit zu bringen dabei hatten
die innenminister der länder bereits
mitte juni beschlossen
dass alle vorkehrungen getroffen werden
um den orts kräften eine schnelle
ausreise nach deutschland zu ermöglichen
doch passiert sei danach nichts
kritisieren die grünen die
bundesregierung habe afghanistan und
flüchtlinge aus dem wahlkampf halten
wollen
der außenminister fand auch dass er
niedrige tage im wahlkampf wohl
hilfreich sind und der minister für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit hat
schriftlich darauf gedrängt dass die
kriterien so befasst werden dass so
wenig menschen wie möglich auch hilfe
bekommen und kanzlerin und vizekanzler
haben zugeguckt ein kollektives versagen
der innenminister ist zuständig für die
sicherheitsüberprüfung der ortskräfte
der vorwurf sein ministerium habe die
sache verzögert
hätte die bundesregierung da schneller
handeln müssen
noch einmal ich habe ihnen unsere
politik will nicht ausweichen ich will
aber auch nicht mit dem finger auf
andere zeigen sie müssen auf die
zu gehen mit denen reden die eigentlich
für ihre fragen zuständig sind gemeint
ist außenminister maß der ist inzwischen
in der defensive
ich trage die politische verantwortung
für alles was im auswärtigen amt
geschieht natürlich auch insbesondere
für die fehler die gemacht werden es
gibt auch ein großes berechtigtes
öffentliches interesse daran dass die
dinge aufbereitet werden muss meint den
bundesnachrichtendienst der hat noch
wenige tage vor dem fall kabuls
behauptet die taliban hätten derzeit
kein interesse die hauptstadt
einzunehmen doch die union nimmt den
geheimdienst in schutz
unsere dienste haben sehr früh bereits
im dezember letzten jahres gesagt dass
kabul kampflos aufgegeben werden wird
der zeitpunkt wurde nur nicht genau
vorhergesehen die bundesregierung habe
die prekäre lage in afghanistan nicht
wahrhaben wollen
wir können es uns nicht mehr leisten
dass man durch die politische brille das
wünschenswerte betrachtet und das
gefährliche ausklammert und das war in
afghanistan der fall ich habe selbst als
abgeordneter über zehn jahre eine
evaluierung angemahnt ich war selbst
lange zeit in afghanistan als soldat
aber all diese waren rufe sind verhallt
markus kroth jahren heute in der
bundespressekonferenz
der offizier war in afghanistan
stationiert er leitet das partnerschafts
netzwerk für afghanischer ortskräfte die
würden mit ihren kindern im stich
gelassen
wir sind von der eigenen regierung
moralisch verletzt und das ist bestimmt
er sieht die hauptverantwortung bei
angela merkel und dem kanzleramt spricht
von unterlassener hilfeleistung
ich mag es am bundeskanzleramt fest im
bundeskanzleramt da ging auch meine e
mails und briefe hinter uns klar war
dass die verschiedenen ministerien sich
gegenseitig blockieren ich habe mehrfach
die kanzlerin angebotenen hilfe
angeboten ich habe versucht darauf
hinzuweisen dass es probleme gibt das
ist leider weder reagiert worden darauf
noch habe ich gesehen dass das
übernommen wurde in meiner sicht ist das
bundeskanzleramt was hätte eingreifen
können aber es leider nicht getan hat
zurück zu mir nach kabul am sonntag
abend meldet er sich bei uns erzählt
dass er wieder am flughafen war
vier männer wurden getötet ich habe ihre
leiche
es wird von tag zu tag schrieb ich ja
ich gehe jetzt nach hause wann ich will
da sehr frustrierend
während tausende ortskräfte in kabul
fest sitzen sind andere schon in
deutschland frontal hat einen getroffen
er will nicht erkannt werden er
arbeitete als übersetzer für die
deutsche botschaft und wurde vor fünf
tagen gerettet
durch besucht die suche nach beamtin
nach damalige
offizieren oder die leute die hier mit
dem ausländer gerettet haben wenn wenn
dem mich gefunden hätten vielleicht wäre
also sehr große gefahr für meine familie
connery ex offizier der bundeswehr hat
ihn nach seiner flucht bei sich
aufgenommen
meine einschätzung ist das ist ein
glücksspiel mit dem leben ein
glücksspiel mit dem leben derjenigen die
20 jahre lang unter der besatzung
friedensmissionen hin oder her mit
darunter irgendwo auch leiden mussten
ich befürchte ja das wenn sich da nichts
ändert dass das zu späteres für viele
vielleicht auch zu spät für amir vor
wenigen stunden erreichen wir ihnen
vergangene nacht hatte er es mit frau
und kindern endlich in den flughafen
geschafft bis zu den kontrollen
als ich zu den deutschen kam haben sie
mir gesagt der name ist nicht auf der
liste bitte geh zurück ich habe ihnen
meine dokumente gezeigt dass sich
ausreise berechtigt bilden doch sie
haben uns aus geschmissen
irgendwas muss total schief gegangen
sein die bundeswehr bestätigt dass armee
den flughafen wieder verlassen musste
und teilt mit alle beteiligten stellen
arbeiten gerade mit hochdruck daran
herren wieder in den flughafen kabul zu
bringen und auszufliegen
die usa wollen in einer woche abziehen
dann enden auch die evakuierungen mit
fatalen folgen für amir und tausende
andere